bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors la période des
soldes a officiellement commencé à
minuit et des soldes qui interviennent
tardivement cette année en raison de la
crise du coronavirus la date du 15
juillet tonte l apix
non je ne tombe pas de tombe vraiment
pas bien d'abord il ya très peu de
touristes les hôtels sont fermées la
plupart en tout cas et la plupart des
parisiens sont déjà partis en vacances
bien son camp chômage partiel et donc
sont pas vraiment paris chuté hier avec
un anneau ambassadeur y est c'est bien
le marché pendant le confinement bas
mais il ya passé une catastrophe allmand
église alors justement à quoi doit-on
s'attendre vu le contexte très marquée
par la crise économique qui a suivi le
confinement des remises exceptionnelles
comment rassurer aussi les les clients
dans ce contexte de très sanitaires vont
les rassurer vous aux hinkle on essaie
en tout cas nous entre nous d'être
d'être solidaires et de 200 voiliers
l'ascenseur vers l'eau de santé d comme
on peut mais comment attraper les les
russes comment attraper les gens
maintenant à paris en tout cas les gens
sont sont partis en vacances on le voit
dans les rues de juba
à la rentrée je ne sais pas ce qu'on
peut faire des choses on aurait dû
proposer les les soldats là à là à la
rentrée pas maintenant surtout est-ce
que vous avez une estimation justement
d'aider des chiffres de
que vous avez perdu que les commerçants
ont perdu pendant cette période
mais hier j'ai eu un deux trois
adhérents et c'est et c'est une
catastrophe
avant on essayé de combler comme on peut
à partir de là à partir de samedi
démarre la nuit aux invalides
moi je fais en soirée le démarrage de
vendredi soir comme pour essayer de
combler les trous j'ai demandé aux
adhérents de se réunir dans des bars
personnes voilà et puis je demande aussi
un metteur en manche s'ils veulent faire
une promotion en présente sur
présentation du ticket mais avant cette
période des soldes qui commencent
aujourd'hui les grandes enseignes ont
cassé leurs prix il ya eu aussi la
période est un des ventes privées
comment est-ce que vous expliquer
justement que les grands en scène l ai
pu faire autant de promotions alors que
les petits commerçants doivent devait
attendre la période officielle des sols
que mon avenir
les grandes enseignes mais elle rend
l'argent l on allait pouvoir elles vont
pouvoir de faire traîner les choses
alors le petit commerçant des petits
chalets faux pas j'ai tout de suite deux
ans nuit voilà l'attitude contrôle et
petits commerçants commerçant n'a pas
les mêmes moyens qu'à une grosse
enseigne c'est difficile en grand avocat
et ensuite celle des choses dernière
question l'état est ce que l'état
continuera à vous aider
et justement petits commerçants on sait
que plusieurs plans de relance ont été
proposés ont été mises en oeuvre pendant
la période du confinement justement pour
venir en aide à ces commerçants
alors là il ya plusieurs car c'est très
très diversifiés certains reçu les 8 500
euros par mois
deux ont déjà dit on à leur tour le saf
redemande déjà les deux pays les charges
les banques n'ont pas joué tout est
maintenant quand je vois le jeu et ça
c'est vraiment dégoûtant mais bon donc
je voulais dire nous on essaie de
s'entraider entre nous et pour l'art la
rentrée un de mes adhérents nous
proposer un fonds pour aider les gens
dans la mode au aider les gens dans la
gastronomie et dans là c'est quand même
les richesses française et il faut
surtout pas perdre
et aujourd'hui sont quand même pas mal
en difficulté merci beaucoup
charles-antoine de la mairie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association des
commerçants du 7e arrondissement de
paris